You know, for all of the fear mongering about
Democrats really being socialists, Obama was
a Marxist.
Bernie is a communist.
All of this stuff, you've been seeing it for
years.
Is it possible that Donald Trump is the most
socialist president that we've ever had, or
at least in decades?
You know, we did a story a year or two ago
about is Donald Trump the first atheist president?
We talked about other non-religious presidents
or presidents believed to be non-religious.
And we talked about the reality that Donald
Trump appears to be lying about being religious
just to try to play, Kate, evangelical voters.
It doesn't make Trump a better president not
to be religious, but he just might not be
religious despite his claims that he loves
the Bible and all of this stuff.
Well, what about Trump?
As a socialist president now, to be clear,
Trump is not a socialist, but we are talking
here about the sort of haphazard definition
of socialism and communism that the right
likes to wrongly ascribe to the ideas of the
left.
But there is a long list of the socialization
of some elements of the economy by Donald
Trump that could arguably make Trump the closest
thing we've had to the definition of a socialist
president that his supporters tend to ascribe
to socialism.
Now, you know, to be clear, there's socialism
and then there's sort of like social democracy
that is sometimes called socialism.
I understand that.
But let's consider this and use the spectrum,
because that's really what it is in terms
of government stimulus, which the right loves
to call socialism.
The first corona virus relief package was
two point two trillion in the Keres Act, trillions
coming in additional forms, trillions pumped
into the market by the Fed.
This is way, way, way bigger than the Obama
stimulus, which they called socialist.
Remember, Obama was a socialist for an 800
billion dollar stimulus bill and for mandating
you buy private health insurance from for
profit companies.
Bush's bank bailout was about 400 billion.
This is like eight trillion in total.
Trump used the Defense Production Act to force
General Motors to make ventilator's after
initial talks broke down over costs.
This is heavy government involvement in directing
the activities of private industry, something
that the right loves to call socialism in
Soviet Russia.
The government tells you what kind of bread
to make.
Trump threatened to condition the sale tick.
Talk to Microsoft on the U.S. receiving a
very big portion of the sale price and said
that nobody else thinks about deals this way
other than him straight up saying government
will take a cut.
Of a private business deal, because why?
Because Trump wants a cut.
If Barack Obama had ever suggested anything
like this, Fox News would have gone bananas
for 10 days.
Donald Trump has massively expanded direct
farm aid from 11 billion in 2017 to more than
thirty two billion in 2020.
Also, he could pay off the farmers who were
hurt by his trade war.
He has socialized a larger portion of agriculture
than previous presidents.
When Harley Davidson wanted to move some of
its manufacturing over to Europe, Trump threatened
them with regulating them and taxing them
like never before.
This is extraordinarily heavy handed in terms
of a government crackdown on a business that
the right calls socialist when a Democrat
suggests doing it.
Trump moved to prop up the local the domestic
coal industry, despite the market deciding
it's time to wrap up coal.
Coal doesn't make sense.
The government is overriding markets to decide
which industry will succeed or fail.
Wow.
And whereas the right on this.
Trump has also raised the deficit massively.
Obama left office with about a 500 billion
deficit, down from one point five trillion.
Remember that deficit, not debt.
Trump doubled where Barack Obama left off
before Corona virus.
And now, obviously with coronavirus, everything
is completely out of control.
The right loves to say those socialist Democrats
raise the deficit.
But it's Trump who's done it historically.
Trump, when asked about debt and deficit,
deflects and talks about, you know, we've
got to build up the military and the wall
and that's going to help the overall economy,
which is almost like a modern monetary theory
type argument, which is just do the projects
and the economy will benefit.
Except Trump's doing it with the wrong projects.
That would make sense to say, you know, improving
health care and education in the short run
might increase the deficit.
But we will benefit so much that in the long
run, it will actually be deficit negative
or deficit neutral.
Trump sort of making that argument.
But with the wrong things like building a
wall as an example.
Now, Trump supporters will say Trump didn't
want to do any socialism, but he had to do
it because of corona virus for the good of
the country.
And that's true, too, to a certain degree.
But it's what he did nonetheless.
A true capitalist would have said, let the
businesses fail.
If you don't want to fly because of a virus,
let the airlines go under.
That's not what Donald Trump is doing.
It's also the experience of FDR, by the way.
I mean, he arguably somewhat reluctantly came
to some of the policies he came to in order
to kind of save capitalism from itself.
Now, FDR is seen by some as the most socialist
president we've had.
Trump has arguably done more.
Presidents have to respond to the events of
their presidency, that's for sure.
You can't remove corona virus from it.
Sort of like imagining Lincoln's presidency
without the civil war or FDR presidency, without
recovering from the Great Depression and World
War Two.
Trump had to deal with Corona virus, but he
chose to do it this way.
It could have been done other ways.
Now, of course, Trump has also done other
things that are not socialistic, right?
He's deregulated business so business can
pollute more, so cars can be less efficient.
Cut funding to agencies, cut taxes for some
people.
But despite all of that, by many measures,
Trump could still be the most socialistic
president in many of our lifetimes.
You've got to go back at least to Nixon, who
created the EPA.
OSHA boosted regulations, Social Security
benefits.
Maybe you'd go back to Dwight Eisenhower,
who passed the Interstate Highway Act.
Subsidized mortgages and college tuition had
a 91 percent top marginal tax rate, despite
lots of ways to reduce the effective tax rate.
What's the reaction from Trump pests?
Absolutely none.
They're too busy trying to suppress the vote
to actually care about what it is that Donald
Trump is doing.
Weird times.
We live in my friends.